[Applaudissements]
c'est donc le moment qu'ils préparent à
commencer par présenter
je suis tellement message dans
l'informatique de les attouchements et
je finissais 3 par la suite chez une
femme de doctorat series et en systèmes
de paiement par la suite j'ai eu
plusieurs expériences dans des
multinationales parce que ça a toujours
été mon rêve malheureusement d'accéder à
me classer malcom chili à bosse j'ai
fait également inscrit donc l'idée c'est
que on a fait quand j'ai fait le passage
rares plusieurs mythes chasse mal et
puis par la suite j'ai pu créer ma
propre boîte digital d'avoir en france
mais également aux gens vers présentes
en algérie
donc aujourd'hui c'est que je vous
donnais
alors partager avec vous ma notre
expérience en matière de développement
de carrière en matière de création de
tartas j'ai eu des expériences qui ont
échangé l'une des extensions réussi et
j'ai essayé de donner ma vision des
choses par rapport aux 6
j'ai commencé par erreur que j'ai fait
dans ma vie c'est que quand j'étais
étudiant à l'insa bouge pas j'avais un
peu de temps libre
en parallèle à ces choses et du coucher
j'ai été créé un réseau social quand
j'avais 18 ans et du coup j'ai commencé
à développer jaunies oui sur des
fonctionnalités genre elle ait partagé
commentaire l'inscription je les drogues
de mon père pour connaissez certainement
et quand j'ai livré une version lite ça
n'a pas marché tout simplement pourquoi
personne ne s'est inscrit du coup à ce
moment là j'ai appris que il faut pas
faire beaucoup d'efforts parfois il faut
travailler intelligemment est la leçon
aujourd'hui la leçon aujourd'hui c'est
que je vais lui qu'il faut pas
réinventer la roue dans quel sens dans
le sens où les choses qui marchent il
faut pas les réinventer ça dira si on a
un but qui marche i 3 essayer de faire
la même chose de faire un copier-coller
par son pouvoir faire de la concurrence
à facebook la deuxième chance aidé par
rapport à amman carrière conjuguant
diplôme donc on fait par rapport à cette
heure à cette expérience nous avons
toujours des drm genre après ma
l'obtention de là on se dit tiens on va
peut être avoir un salaire stable et on
va intégrer les avants marché les
changements en danger
mon choix parce qu'on me rends à l'air
tous partagent de 7500 où il ira un
salaire d'un ingénieur débutant mais
vous devez savoir que cette source de
revenus n'est jamais suffisante en corse
qui aurait dû commencer à remonter et 87
fait rire du tout au long du match des
espoirs adidas 2 après tu prends 200 du
coup ça faut pas s'attendre à ce que
c'est vraiment s'améliorer et du coup
j'ai appris que avec nécessaire je ne
peux pas faire même passé un petit
appartement
et comme à casablanca c'est pour ça que
j'ai détruit par à ce rythme il faut
avoir une deuxième source de revenus et
qui est le village
alors aujourd'hui je ne suis pas contre
le fait d'intégrer des multinationales
pourquoi parce qu'on va apprendre
énormément de choses mais problème c'est
que cette source de revenu c'est 30 de
grand-fort vous avez créé ne va pas vous
permettre de créer vraiment de la
richesse
la troisième erreur que j'ai commise
également c'est que j'ai passé
énormément de temps à développer pour
les autres et d'aborder des projets et
être souvenirs à l'accent est soumis à
une organisation à un organigramme est
de vous je me suis retrouvé dans une
zone de confort plus je me maquille
pourquoi parce que j'étais ingénieur
comme les autres j'ai commencé à grimper
en crescendo
je commence à avoir des chefs de projet
junior chef de projet senior et le
salaire est la cause a grimpé de
mitterrand 1500 dirhams
mais ça n'a jamais été mon rêve de
rester salarié du coup j'ai un jour
décidé de changer la situation et de me
lancer dans le monde de deux stars dame
demande l'entrepreneuriat pour lui la
ligue que je tirais par rapport à cette
expérience
il faut oser et aux essais commencent
membres a réussi donc à la suite j'ai
lancé ma première star table qui
s'appelle sinar mas cinat c'est une idée
que dans ma barbe ottawa qui mon associé
et en a pensé à créer un site web de
grand de noble orly n'aura donc c'est en
fait ceci près qu'ils avaient choisi
marc pas encore nous pouvons apprendre
parce qu'on a commencé la partie
internationale est là on fait ce qu'on a
fait c'est compliqué de table ont acheté
des photos de chats sont que vous
pressez certainement citibank images et
nous avons commencé à partager ses
photos sur facebook et on a commencé à
recevoir des mondes
et quand par magie ça a marché or une
fois on a commencé à avoir des gourmands
donc chaque jour aux abords c'est un
petit corps en début parasites et
commencent à augmenter aujourd'hui en
fait enfin à 25 secondes par jour et en
a verrouillé le process et honnêtement
il ya certes du tour automatique mans je
me fais rien au génie qui en fait la
personne qui nous lisent sur facebook
d'autres personnes reçoivent est grande
une troisième personne ivre donc on
avait remis la sarthe at on est passé à
autre chose
la neuvième en fait que j'appelle 5,6
tandis qu'en fait c'était le site web et
j
et là je ne suis pas et sûrement lui il
faut pas réinventer la roue et j'ai
remarqué que josiane font des affaires
en part de 30 millions de dirhams en sus
allemand dans tout ce que je sais c'est
que je contacte un retard qui a d'abord
à qui vont des produits panda en fait on
a intégré les produits dans un but ici
monique hamas qu'ils avaient les faits
et l'or a commencé à commercialiser en
forme est malade
sur facebook sur mon chagrin on reçoit
des grandes chaînes livre a bondi à
travers al manar haut niveau est chargé
mais le chiffre d'affaires donc c'est un
succès sa part commencé un peu plus
souvent un an
aujourd'hui est faible quand même elle a
dépassé 3 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et en parallèle parce que
j'avais les moyens j'ai commencé à
gagner de l'argent de choix j'ai
commencé à penser à l'entrepreneuriat
j'ai recruté votre guise j'ai revu de
l'énergie qui parce que ça a toujours
été le monde de se lancer dans le grand
bain shipping je sais pas d avis comment
ils sont plus simple c'est peu dire le
droit
xining dans le coaching en fait c'est
très simple c'est que vous ramenez des
produits à l express de la paroisse et
vous les vendez d'en bardou différents
types de produits illégaux de
d'éléphants b des chargeurs des trucs de
cosmétiques de maytag donc en âge plus
produit à 1 $ et alix dre en chine quand
le livre en aval et en levant avant toi
là et vous fait que l'intermédiation
entre les deux parties prenantes est
finalement j'ai pensé à créer l'agencé
fitch mondial en 2002 ans c'est une
agence digitale qui est spécialisé dans
la création de vingt ans environ
stratégique des entreprises vendent ou
skier stratégie digitale communication
360 a découvert les différents canaux
d'acquisition et non figée changer
carrément de l'assiette asmo débarquant
vous savez je suis un ingénieur en
informatique mais ma passion là n'a
jamais été le candidat
corning le fait de développer etc ç'a
toujours été le même de bord des trains
de communiquer une grande entrée nous
barça charles lynch et s'est du coup je
me suis orienté vers avant de se
convertir et le marketing digital et
pour ne rien vous cacher là le bac
technique janeiro à travers l'île il
était comme elle a énormément aidé parce
qu une jointure très solidement du
marketing digital et de techniques sur
le développement et la vie dès
aujourd'hui c'est que grâce à cette
agence
j'ai vu comme la compagnie plusieurs
multinationales dans tout ce qui est
communication digitale on travaille
aujourd'hui avec nestlé mais on
travaille également avec boxes un parti
jeune roi farouk avec de riches comme le
service militaire c'est moins qu'à
lancer toute la campagne rather moi mes
équipes au premier
l'idée c'est que remmener on a été bien
digérée à travailler sur des grands
projets et aujourd'hui c'est que
l'opportunité d'enrichir et de vraiment
assez important c'est pour ça que je
vais vous montrer en fait quelques
techniques ou comment un entretien en
moins le monde du génial
or cette expérience m'a montré le
principal c'est que pour faire des
investissements et pour gagner de
l'argent parce que l'argent c'est très
important dans ma vie j'ai un peu peur
mais l'idée c'est que pour avoir accès à
ces challenges ou à ces entreprises
c'est assez pas cet esprit
d'entrepreneuriat il faut quand même
avoir du sens de moi quand j'étais
étudiant à l'insa je n'ai pas cessé de
travailler en free minces parce que
c'est très important
d'abord parce que je suis très modeste
j'avais besoin d'argent pour financer
mes études mais l'idée d'avancer que le
moment du frimas l'entrepreneuriat te
permet de vraiment belle plusieurs
capacités de communication mais surtout
de revenus et on reparle de revenus en
parle automatiquement de d'injection de
l'investissement
donc maintenant je vais vous montrer 4
astuces pour gagner facilement de
l'argent parce que quand je vous
expliquais l'idée de gagner d'argent à
travers la finale nous permettra
d'ailleurs d'un désherbant buzzer
crémant d'alsace ava également nous
permettre d'avoir cette indépendance
financière qui est très importante
le premier volet c'est le community
manager donc je vous expliquerai ce que
ça veut dire le communisme en allemagne
avec des gens mais en d'organiser
aujourd'hui c'est que chaque entreprise
ou adjacent à casablanca est une page
facebook en vous savez la magie ça ira
or l'idée d'ajouter des formations je
vais monter des community managers qui
gère des pages vous pouvez gérer des
vaches de restaurants modèle est celle
que vous vous faire un revenu mensuel
fixe pendant qu aujourd'hui par exemple
la case anglaises sont les parents de
freelance arguments du community
management génère quand même des revenus
importants parle de cinq missiles à
parme en partage bornes jean est très
simple justement d'adapter une version
que certaines moreau vous pouvez avoir
des contacts dans la famille il est très
recommandé de commencer par les grands
axes de la famille modeste quand même et
du coup par la suite vous pouvez affiner
jeunes est une page facebook
g
mettre du contenu produire du contenu
genre l'obélix vous invite à visiter à
lui visité aussi par exemple les
pâtisseries du coin on peut également
appliquer la même chose
également dans le community management
ya la partie gestion des commentaires et
des messages donc vous pourrez également
se baser sur sur les femmes sur le
l'historique des normes claires pour
proposer des réponses automatiques
bâtiment ajoute pour moi c'est une sorte
or il est très facile à aborder et qu'il
est très facile à ration la deuxième
technique fait une chose que moi j'ai
toujours faim sais c'est que quand
j'étais étudiant j'ai toujours créé des
sites web donc tout ce que je faisais ce
que je pense et d avance sur glissement
sur instagram
j'ai demandé aux gens si vous voulez
créer des sites web je me rappelle très
bien un premier cycle que j'ai demandé
c'était une ovation petite progression
de manchots rouge là on frise qui
voulait avoir un psy chic web doit vite
sam en briques en amour deux jours de
travail
et puis par la cie première libération
des 2 500 500 kg bronzé comme ça à
développer des sites web des sites web
et à ce que je suis arrivé à développer
quand même à plus de 180 sites web au
nom de mon père me remplit aujourd'hui
c'est le fait de développer l'histoire
du tournage compliqué vous avez décidé à
gratot des solutions qui vous permet de
dénombrer les sites web français en se
basant sur des pans des vers sur weeks
oui c'est une solution du développement
de sites web qui est vraiment très
facile pour des gradins drop à travers
car avoir aidé au go en me faire des
déplacements etc d'un guide et de
produits de développement des histoires
c'est une presse
sont des services très regrettée
dorothée beaucoup du nord pour des
lancements en ressortent de la part de
nos clients qui est le développer ce
créneau avoir de visiteurs du kitsch et
a donc ça c'est une chose qui n'existe
pas d'avoir une boîte et nécessite pas
d'avoir un bébé c'est un truc hyper sain
la troisième chose je vous incite mes
amis rares tirs sur le groupe shipping
le groupe swing aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la tendance du marché
c'est à dire aujourd'hui tout le temps
tout le process ou loire que de les
classer en train de changer
ça ne risque pas à les amazones
dernièrement les chiffres d'avril fonds
etc et tout ça c'est grâce à des
nouveaux concepts brotchi fixe est très
présente
l'idée c'est de rentrer dans l express
par exemple de sélectionner un film là
vous enverra lessard exemple moi je me
sens à l'aise dans la pêche soit les
produits de pêche ont par exemple de la
preuve d'un produit cosmétique ou magro
les jouets d'enfants etc
et là je commence à gré en sorte que je
devais automatiquement sans avoir besoin
du mans paiement si qnx des écrits par
exemple et acheter acheter il y avait
parfois aujourd'hui n'en crée pas
d'emplois comme exemple choper va
changer c'est une grande déception quand
même un certain nombre de retraités qui
sont assez semblables est monté et une
ville en direct à 20h30 marc herman donc
champ de maïs à vancouver ou documents d
il ya plein de courses sur youtube et
vous pouvez la science une résidence et
ce à l'intérieur de d'avoir une
visibilité sur cinq est finalement pour
les gens qui me veulent masse casser la
tête pour ça elle une solution également
passés ensemble
j'imaginais un grand besoin de gina au
niveau des villes de la région du nul
le commerce local alors le commerce
local ces cours vendeur par exemple des
grossistes à zilina qui ramène des
produits fragiles ou de produits de
masse et vous vous êtes justement
prendre son envol de sport prendre
uniquement la liste des produits les
maîtres sont facebook sont soumises à
travers une gamme de 5 $ ou du douar
sait comment ça et croyez moi les b -
mot commence à rentrer etc
elle a toujours passé j'ai donné ce
chiffre d'affaires généré ce budget je
vous demande de faire et ça va vraiment
aider à avancer parce que l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est que il faut éviter de
perdre du temps dans des choses qui ne
vont pas faire de la valeur ajoutée
aujourd'hui monique d'avoir une vision
orientée chiffre d'affaires est très
importante parce que c'est ça le
principe que des extras toujours
toujours un promu c'est le principe de
couleur le blanc ap c'est le principe
des cartables qui bosse chez objets
auxquels c'est super tu as un salaire
mais c'est pas suffisant a besoin d'une
autre entrée d'argent sur vraiment faire
ce que tu as acheté des quatre cadres
j'assume culture c'est avoir une autre
source de revenus en parallèle évident
aujourd'hui c'est se lancer sur des
spectacles où se lancer sont des mini
projets qui vont aider à générer du
chiffre d'affaires en barrages en gros
c'est ça
aujourd'hui présenté également remercier
toute l'équipe d'organisation de cet
événement et c'est énorme de plaisir
qu'il soit aujourd'hui par mon goût
[Applaudissements]